this week on quad riga neo Nazi terror
trial lessons for Germany Germany has
begun the probe into the right-wing
terror group the national socialist
underground the NSU with the opening of
the trial of Fiat a cheaper chip is
accused of involvement in the murder of
nine people with a migrant background
and a policewoman two bombings and a
series of bank robberies carried out all
over Germany over a period of more than
10 years along with her two accomplices
cheaper remained undetected the NSU's
existence only came to light in 2011
politicians police and media did not
link the murders to right-wing extremism
so what lessons has Germany to learn
from the NSU case your host today ally
Aslam hello and welcome to quadriga how
could a murderous neo Nazi terror cell
go on killing over ten people for over a
decade in Germany and not be detected by
German security officials and now that
the trial has finally gone under way
what are the lessons that need to be
drawn from this case that and more i
will discuss on today show with my three
experts welcome to mammoth I'm Aguilar
who is a lawyer representing several of
the victims families he is also the
author of a book which looks critically
at how integration and immigration is
being dealt with in Germany John Gertz
is an award-winning investigative
journalist who works for germany's
public broadcaster ard he's also the
co-author of the book feed seller which
looks at the origins of the NSU and
Melissa Eddie is the Berlin
correspondent for the International
Herald Tribune she's been covering the
trial from the very beginning Melissa
Eddie you were at the courtroom in
Munich a lot of media attention not just
German but also international media
attention as well what stood out for you
most what are the impressions that that
that have stuck with you from the first
day I think the media attention
was definitely one of the one of the
impressions there were more media in in
the room that was open to the general
public then there were general public
you had a handful of people who had been
there from the day before they came
already on the Sunday in order to get in
and everyone thought there would be a
crush but 15 minutes before the
courtroom to open people were still
getting in line who were able to get in
and that's something for example the
damiana trial that was that was not seen
the other thing that stood out was a
certain I think there was just sort of
overall a sense of relief that the trial
was starting having been delayed that at
least now it's moving ahead and perhaps
the last thing was I was somewhat
surprised at how heavily the focus was
on bad at a perimeter presentation which
there's a lot to say about but it almost
sort of over became the overriding theme
of the trials opening which i think is
unfortunate and we'll talk and deep more
about the sole focus of beata JP and the
ramifications mem atomic that you were
also in the courtroom in Munich
representing several of the victims
families what was your impression I was
sitting among the victim families
orphans widows and I really was deeply
impressed by the dignity of these people
who suffered so much they lost their
loved ones and then they were not
allowed to be a victim they were
suspected for all the cake decade
well-beings murders without having any
any hint for that and still the people
survived and they waited for this day
and then they were sitting in front of
the suspected murderers and the way they
dealt with this difficult duration
impressed me very much these people did
not call for revenge they are just
waiting for justice and indeed John
Gertz the trial as both the military and
me madam ecclair's has finally underway
it's been postponed for a few weeks over
the controversy over the yellow
occasion of media seats finally is now
underway and the focus very much is on
beata chapin do you think that this sole
focus this predominant focus on be out
of the chip is misleading well I mean
pay at a cheaper is on trial I mean
never see reason was I mean I think what
we all find distasteful and disgusting
that it was all about her what she was
wearing and was about how she had her
hair and and how I mean that issue I
thought was distasteful and you know the
victims families is something that
didn't get reported on in the same way
and a lot of people are saying this
could not have been the work of a
so-called trio of just three people
they're saying beata JP obviously the
only surviving member of this trio /
burn hot and over Mont loss committed
suicide right after basically they were
found out and discovered what do you
make of this do you think that the focus
on this trio is also misleading well I
mean what about this trio in the
beginnings of this trio in your book
yeah I mean they came out of a very
racist atmosphere of the early 1990s and
you can really make an argument that
they basically stayed true to theirs to
the stew themselves to themselves you
know in the early 1990s there was an
atmosphere in the early 1990s in Germany
where every weekend you know refugee
homes were attacked and fire bombed and
and that's the atmosphere that they kind
of that this whole cell grew out of and
of course in order to kind of have that
education and in order to go underground
you need support and you need people who
support you supporters and you know
financial help and that kind of thing
and they did have people who helped them
there was a network of people that
helped them I do not believe though that
the broader neo-nazi movement was
involved with them in the ten years that
they were on their murder spree and
Melissa Eddie if we look at how racism
is being discussed in Germany and has
been up on to
this point do you think it's sufficient
I think there's a lot more that needs to
be done Germany has the tendency which
is understandable given Germany's
history of looking at history and
considering racism to largely be within
the realms of World War two in the
Holocaust and and with that as well the
idea that that racism must go hand in
hand with a political motive and I think
that is hampering the ability to have a
broader discussion on racism of just
thinking oh you don't look like me and
and what does that mean that I
automatically think about you and I
think when we get into this trial and
looking at at some of the deeper
problems of why why did nobody think
racism is is behind this when you have
very clearly somebody who is targeting
Turks or people who look like Turks
because there are 10 of them or nine of
them excuse me the and then the police
woman it just it seems almost
unbelievable that the racism does not
automatically jump into mind and and I
think that discussion needs to happen
and i think this trial would give the
country a chance to have that discussion
and and and they need to have that
discussion because they've shown in the
past that that they can't have a
discussion about about the repercussions
of racism and what it means but that
needs to be brought up now it needs to
be taken out of the past and brought to
the present day and and looking ahead to
the future madam aguilera is this
country ready to have this discussion
already or not we need to have this
discussion and from my perspective it
was nearly a taboo to even speak about
racism especially after nine eleven the
only topic you were not allowed to talk
about was Islamism but racism no feed
large we have we do not have racism but
we do have racism i have read like three
hundred thousand pages of files
pertaining this case and there was one
report the police report written by
senior police officers do to develop
something like profile was in january
2007
and there was one sentence which really
was hard for me to read because I could
not believe what I was reading they
stated since it is a taboo in our
culture to kill somebody the murderers
need to come from outside the wealth 30
police also have worked on this paper
dozens of superiors have read it and
nobody said or hold on it's not only
grotesque be wrong but it's also racist
no it was nobody stood up because this
is a kind of socially accepted racism
and since it's socially accepted it's
not racism and it's a problem in my
opinion we need to talk about that and
in the jungles for the longest time
police and German security officials
looked within the Turkish community
didn't they to shed light on these
killings how do you explain this that
that not one of them bothered to at
least raise the question that perhaps
there was a racial motive behind this
what's fascinating is it you had the FBI
was asked to consult on the case and you
know with and within a week or I don't
came over the exact no number of days
they worked on the case they came back
and said I think you should look for a
racist murderer right I mean and it's it
is because the FBI is not frequently not
correct on a lot of things I mean it was
you know is amazing that they came up
with that analysis so quickly I mean I
think it reflects a really profound
institutional racism within the police
and security forces right and you know
there's you know they the fact that it
was assigned to organized crime the
whole the cases were assigned to
organized crime and then they only look
to organized crime I mean they then it's
their job to stick and only look for
organized crime and I submit to you that
virtually any of us if you go four or
five general you know four or five
cousins will find somebody who's
involved in some kind of drug dealing
Jimmy I mean if you really just I mean
it's just six degrees of separation and
so they were able to find some weird
distant relative of the victims who was
involved in some kind of thing and then
that all became part of their huge
organized crime conspiracy which was
nonsense amendment I'm agree that John
guts talked about the institutionalized
racism in
in Germany how widespread you think this
racist mindset is in security services
and institutions in Germany well we have
racism in society and we did have a
report or sites paper from the fridge a
budget of tone talking about racism
especially eastern Germany so twenty
percent or so of society are for example
following anti-semitic patterns so very
basically asked we have 270,000 police
officers security force in Germany and
it's say only one percent are in some
kind involved too real neo-nazi or
racist ideas we are talking about 2,700
police officers and we know that the
average in societies much higher and so
I think we have a problem and I think we
are living in Nile I've spoken with one
or two members of the planetary an
investigation committee on this case and
I've asked them whether or not they
intend to talk about array institutional
racism and they were like like shocked
no no no this is not the topic but i
think yet this is a topic we need to
talk about who we are as Germans and we
need to talk about how the garments the
police is responding to the fact that
Germany has changed a lot I was last 50
or or 50 40 or 50 years we now are a
multicultural multi-religious country
but our police forces or not and I said
let me rephrase the question that how
widespread do you think racism is in
German society well first of all just to
build on what he said I think it's very
interesting because this parliamentary
committees was to be tasked with coming
up with suggestions and there's a very
clear suggestion is you know to address
racism to some extent within the police
forces but also within many of the other
official offices I think it bleeds into
the immigration debate and and the
integration debate you know I find it
very fascinating in this country you
talk about integration and it sort of
has become also an institution of itself
but where's the reality of it where does
it act where does it integrate
it actually take price this kind of
integration and I think there needs to
be a way to move beyond just that focus
on this word and having politicians meet
with a handful of or like the minister
with free to this meeting with a handful
of people and and trying to say okay
we're going to talk about this or that
that's not that's not integration it has
to it has to start reaching a level a
more basic level where people feel
welcome regardless of where they come
from and and what religion they follow
or don't follow but I really crazy I
mean it's just this it's a crazy game I
mean because I mean the people who are
refusing to integrate at the Germans
right I mean there's this whole notion
that that the foreign community where
the immigrant community is refusing to
integrate is absolutely not the case I'm
thinking in terms of learning the
language tutors are going to German
schools being a part of German society
paying taxes Jane I mean the people who
refuse and immigrate is the dominant you
know the majority culture the refusing
to allow that that that integration to
to join them if you will there's there's
this real sort of defense against a live
in a there's a great you know of course
not all Germans right but is it there's
a there's a big part of the population
that has an image of Germany and and
their understanding of what the society
is is pre-1950 right you don't I mean
that it's basically were you know one
dimension one you know one religion one
you know ethnic commute you know state
and that kind of remains the self
understanding of the country and they
and in terms of the fact that it has
radically changed in the last 50 years
people don't like to kind of take that
into their daily decisions their daily
understanding of where they live an
example of that just real quickly
getting back to the trial I have to say
and maybe you could speak a bit more of
this when the judge went through and was
reading off the names of all of the
lawyers who are there representing the
the co-plaintiffs the neden clayey he
stumbled over a lot of those Turkish
names and I felt that that he I felt
that was really lacking in respect and
there was even one woman who he thought
he called her hair I can't remember her
he stumbled over it so I wasn't able and
she she basically said them know I'm I'm
a woman and you've got pretty much all
of it wrong and that she pronounced her
name properly and I thought if you're
going to read these names out in front
of a court you owe it you these are
lawyers these are in a way you're your
peers in this profession you owe it to
them to be able to pronounce their names
and if you can't pronounce them there's
somebody who will help you and rehearse
it before you before you before the
general public go out and and you know
that being a German with a Turkish
background you don't spend time to think
about stuff like this you're right but
you know we have we are dealing with
much bigger stuff let me let me be peers
at one example when last year mr. West
about our foreign minister paid a visit
to the chairman of the church community
of Germany mr. Collett 2442 voice
condolences right it was right to go
between mr. Khalid but the first
question is why is a foreign minister I
mean these people were citizens of this
country and number of them had even
German passports so postmortem they were
declared foreigners people who are not
belonging to the society and the
killings were called during a murder
that was something is foreign the
investigation committee from the police
the special committee was called
Bosporus committee you know all the
stuff is again again pertaining and
perpetrating the idea that this people
doing it did not belong actually to this
country and I think the whole idea of
integration we need to define what
integration means because we don't have
any sense of your definition of a common
definition I think somebody working here
paying his taxes trying to learn German
is pretty much integrated in my opinion
but integration is not a one-way street
I think integration is adapting to a
reality and we all have to adapt to
dredge the world is changing every day
in many many terms socially but also
technology for example if you are not
adapting if you are not integrating we
will lose contact to other to the
development so the idea is that only in
you
newcomers have to integrate is Percy not
correct and John Gertz this new naughty
terror cell the NSU has gone killing at
least ten people ten that we know of for
over a decade they've gone undetected by
German security officials and it's bad
enough if authorities have turned a
blind eye to the crimes of the
right-wing extremists it's another if
they were part inactive complicit part
because there are some people are saying
intelligent falls on the NSU were
destroyed and some are even asking if
intelligence agencies assisted the NSU
what's your opinion well i mean i i've
worked on the case since november 2011
and have worked you know for the
süddeutsche zeitung and for ard and we
have looked as hard as we possibly could
to find any evidence of complete a
police complicity terms of aiding and
abetting assisting the these neo-nazis
and we found no evidence at all I found
no evidence at all of them directly
aiding in any way at all what there's
massive evidence of is institutional
racism I mean an inability to actually
kind of look at what's right in front of
your face you know not listening to
witnesses not listening to the victims
families you know who said oh we think
it's skinheads there were eyewitnesses
who thought it was skinheads there were
people who made a connection between the
Nuremberg killing and Dortmund bombing
you know from from the air so there's
all that kind of stuff IC bristling no
evidence of any security force
involvement in the killings but yeah
well first of all you know we know that
files important files has been shredded
in the headquarters of the dramatic
Secret Service but then i have to
mention the killing of mr. yozgat in
castle was a young guy he was killed in
his internet cafe very much the same
moment a Secret Service agent was a taxi
of the crime and we do not have a
convincing explanation yet for what
have done there so you saying we do not
have evidence it's not really fully
convincing me because one evidence has
been destroyed and secondly we have this
guy sitting in this Annette coffee and
then right after the killing of Michigan
Scott just going away without you know
reporting to the police as a witness he
was found later and he was found to be
maybe and not himself because everybody
his village start else's or he's called
little adult and he has also snotty
material in his apartment so we do have
question marks and not as a shocking
thing is I'm a lawyer in Germany I trust
my country and now a year later only a
year after i have no takes his job I
have to ask this kind of questions well
and I was used to ask this kind of
question the countries like Belarus or
Zimbabwe and now we're talking about
Germany and so you think that the police
and secret intelligence and secret
services in Germany have actively aided
the NSU no I do not think that but I'm
not excluding any kind of idea we have
to investigate it and this is in part
the job of a trial but i'm not going to
start this trial with any kind of blind
spots from the very beginning we need to
deal with this case in a very very
open-minded way rather than saying no no
this is not possible this is something
which can only happen in some mediocre
countries outside europe no no we have
to be very very focused and have to
follow every hint in this case in castle
is a big question mark i do not how do
you are you're sinking boxes yo Scott
kidding case I mean I mean we have any
in US history we have you know i think
it was 24 Black Panthers were just
killed by the FBI right and we have
another shot with I mean if this I don't
know of any evidence including the
castle case that the police were
actively involved there was a Secret
Service agent in the cafe when the man
was killed which is absolutely strange
in the
explanations are not there I think that
there's a real problem though with the
notion that that so many people are
focused on where the security services
involved or not and that it's actually
kind of the wrong debate throughout the
real debate i think is actually racism
in german society and the institutional
racism in the police forces equally
important to ask whether the secrets
intelligence and secret services were
involved no yeah but it's I think it's a
detour it's a detour that's not going
anywhere and it and then so then every
German can like oh ok well there's no
proof I mean I only agreed parts because
we are literally talking about two
levels one is the investigation of the
crime we have to do that and we cannot
cannot accuse somebody or execute
somebody from the very beginning we have
to be open-minded the broader debate in
society about who we are about racism
anti-semitism homophobia Islamophobia
all the stuff we need to have this
debate we need to conduct this but we
are not doing it yet and I hope that the
trial and the cup media coverage on the
trial might trigger this kind of debate
I hope it I'm not really optimistic but
I hope we can can achieve it olicity is
it possible that so much in competence
happens at once over the time span of a
decade what do you make of this hi so
far I mean I I don't have the deep view
into all of the files and the documents
that they have it from from my
perspective it appears that that yes it
was possible and I think history has
shown also in the United States cases
where where authorities have overlooked
things I think it's part of what makes
covering this trial really difficult is
there are so many possible detours and
not only the trial this the whole
history you can delve into it in a real
deep investigative manner but if you
want to try and trigger this public
debate you have to find a way to be able
to do that to be able to get people
talking about it and I think that that
makes
challenge of covering this as a
journalist it's very great because you
have to pick and choose where do you
want to delve where do you want to probe
where do you wear what what do you want
to highlight and and I i agree i don't
know if this will trigger the debate
that it needs to trigger or not and and
obviously covering this from from the
international perspective is different
than my colleagues who cover this for
the german media you think we see i've
covered the security forces and and
intelligence services in germany now for
a long time and just the staggering and
competence right and i think that's
something that people don't realize is
is these are people who have to fill out
forms to leave the building i mean i'm
exaggerating a little bit but the idea
that they would take initiative to do
anything is just it just doesn't it
doesn't reflect a knowledge of again a
staggering and competence kind of you
know they're out of the building you
know at 301 on friday afternoon that
that's the kind of scene that we're
talking about you know the headquarters
of the German secret service in Cologne
just imagine situation on namba um
assert as I when I remember rightly the
NSU was discovered and then the Attorney
General decided seizes a state security
case and only two days later a Secret
Service agent started shredding
important files two days later now we
can you can call it in competence but
the same guys he wrote a guy we brought
in a protocol the minutes of the
chattering and dated it back to februari
you know in order to disguise the fact
that he responded directly to the move
of the trailer general if it was not
incompetent it was not a case of
incumbent it was a deliberate effort to
disguise what happened is not is not
incompetent was it to disguise that the
Germans is you know a domestic
intelligence service was involved in the
whole thing or was it disguised if he
had files that in his office that he
shouldn't have kept so long I mean
that's the thing that I think that those
people are obsessed with is some little
tiny regulation that they haven't been
following correctly I mean that's that I
mean I just don't see the ominous I and
I think the discussion about if you can
come up with three guys from the
intelligence service who were involved
in the murders in some ways it's an
easier truth to deal with than the fact
that the society has got a huge a
problem right I mean rather than three
bad apples that if you can actually see
that the institution itself rots that
that's a more dangerous and a more
difficult thing to talk about you're
right mr. goods but again again we have
to deal with both of it and both topics
are interconnected right you can't just
say okay we're not going to dig deeper
in what happened within the security
forces because we have to give us a
bigger idea of racism now we have to do
both well no no I think that we've been
hijacked by the conspiracy theory right
we've been hijacked diet because I don't
think it's going anywhere and I and and
I I mean I really spin I mean it'd be a
great story I've worked on it for a long
time trying to find any evidence it's
just I just don't have any again again
we need to do not need to talk about a
conspiracy well it's what we've totally
sufficient if you have people the sin as
a system who are doing what they think
is right to do with some kind of right
races sinking again the report from the
button Wittenberg police saying it's not
part of our culture 22 butta butta
killer this is a racist thinking this is
not conspiracy and i'm not talking about
conspiracy i am not believing in
controversy more i do not want to
believe in conspiracy but i'm talking
about institutional racism and i'm not
saying okay in some cases as much it
might be just a stupid mistake to have
dances or that this happened to
incompetency but i'm also thinking
things happened very deliberately
because of institutional racism you know
what one of the victims daughter she
told me you know what if all the nine
migrants we are not my organs but
Germans this case has been you know
solve much earlier and sadly enough I
have to agree and this is not
controversy and military whether it was
in competence or perhaps even more
regardless of the fact it remains that
close to three million Turks living in
Germany and German teryx there believe
in this country has been shaken has a
naught they believe in the justice
system in Germany has been under mine is
that perhaps the even greater danger
here I think it's definitely a danger I
think also if you look at it from the
from the outside world that the Germany
has to be careful Germany has a lot
going for it right now economically but
but something like this really makes
people question as John was saying the
core what is it the core or core of the
society and and it's also dangerous that
if you're trying to push for integration
and and now you have this this reason
for for the people who you're trying to
reach to not believe in in the society
that they're supposed to be integrating
into I think that makes it definitely
much more difficult and much more
challenging to try and get that message
across I also think if you look at
everything that has been done you know
the Chancellor apologized last year at
the official ceremony there was the
official ceremony but then it kind of
fell off the map again I think the
hardest thing with this is to keep it
going in this dialogue to try and and
make it not just this apology or your
president gowk was then in Strasbourg
and he also said oh well this is
terrible all of that has been said it
needs to go into the next step somebody
needs to be thinking about okay how do
we take this and learn what it what is a
lesson what is something concrete that
we can do not just to prevent this
happening again but to try to address
the problems that allowed this this to
happen and indeed Chancellor Merkel has
called the killings in national disgrace
the u UN Human Rights Council has called
these killings the worst human rights
violations in Germany in the last decade
clearly an embarrassment
this country John Gertz yeah absolutely
an embarrassment yeah I mean but I mean
I'm not so worried about Germany's image
in the world I'd like to see it actually
hurt in terms of what it goes on here
for it to change I mean one of the
fascinating things is that if you're an
immigrant in Germany but if you're born
in Germany as an immigrant if your
mother's an immigrant right I don't know
if you interpret law at least until
recently it says on your foreigner file
your date of entry into Germany is the
day of your birth so the way that German
law looks at your mother is actually
walking foreign territory in Germany and
rather than dove you know citizenship
laws that you have in other countries
that you're born someplace you're
automatically if you wish to be a
citizen of that country and we're still
don't even have that kind of level of
citizenship lawyer and military already
erased an important question momentum
Aguilera indeed if we look further if
you don't look behind even though it's
inevitable in this particular case and
in association with the trial but if we
look into the future what must Germany
learn from this case we must we have to
understand that being a German is not a
matter of blood or some obscure idea of
blood well we have we need to understand
that being a German my opinion is taking
responsibility for this country saying
I'm part of it no matter what and it has
to start on a governmental and legal
level making people easier to become a
citizen of this country you know i was
born in this country and i need it like
22 years to get a German passport but
coming from there it has to be a part of
of education of the way we are having we
are having debates somebody who is has a
migration background Jeremy know that
people are asking me where you're from
and I was getting out it's close to
Cologne no way you're very from our okay
i was born in the video in the village
of nia Sheldon no no where you're really
from it is really from is
not assigned for curiosity it's just a
sign I have for my perspective sign for
I'm not really accepted no matter what
and this is something which has to
change I don't want that my nephews and
grandnephews have to know go to sue that
they have as I should feel safe again
this is my my country's is a good
country and because it's good it's worth
fighting for and it's wrong just to
neglect problems we have got and I think
it's a sign for a mature society and
mature democracy really to address
problems yeah for like 10 or 15 years
ago a young guy a young man was killed
in London he was born in the UK but his
parents came from Jamaica it was killed
because he was black and and the
security forces saf failed to
investigate and they filled in a way
which reminds me may mean many many
terms in the NSU case and then the House
of Lords establish a committee to
mcpherson committee and they brought a
report at this report was very hard and
very very very honest and they address
the problem of institutional racism and
you know what the people in the United
internet kingdom they discussed they
fought about this paper but at the end
they learn something they learn that
they have to change the attitude of the
security forces and this is for me a
sign for a very mature democracy we can
learn from that job guys can only agree
that's that's exactly what this country
new trainer on but even if we look and
you're a journalist you're a journalist
as well if we look at how the German
media for instance has been following
these killing spree for over a decade
you'd say it was also a massive
breakdown in in freedom of press know at
the end of the day the media completely
uncritically adopted the the police line
that the killings must have been within
the inner Turkish community I think it
gets into the the idea of what of what
mr. gates was saying about institutional
racism it's it's also a certain
institution but I agree absolutely the
idea that donor
mod you know kebab killings effectively
we would say in English was just picked
up immediately nobody questioned it and
in fact I I'd read about it before I
really sort of delved into into this in
2011 I assumed stupidly now I think that
that all of these these men who were
killed must have been running kebab
stands one of them was only one of them
was but it was the impression that you
got if you didn't delve into it and
really in really try to figure out what
was going on and and some of the victims
as well said said how hurtful that was
which I can imagine one of one of the
victims whose father had had built up
this business here an entrepreneur he
had he'd been successful and Germany
should have been thrilled that this guy
was able to come in and do this and
instead he was written off as a dead
kebab stand guy and that's it would be
like if there was a series of killings
against Americans calling him hamburger
murders dude I mean all right I just you
know just disgusting hey right and I
think again the media and I had
mentioned this in the beginning this
focus now suddenly on what Chapo was
wearing I mean obviously everybody's had
been waiting to see her because it's
been a year there was this build-up but
there were also if one really watched
her you could tell this was her front
this was her moment and to me it sort of
spoke to her ability to have run this
whole show that she was able to look
very professional but when she shifted
from leg to leg she picked her
fingernails you could tell that she was
nervous and and that she knew what was
at stake here and and she was that was
her sort of you know I won't go down
with a fight just to focus on that she
had her hair dyed um sort of made me
think where is this gonna get us that's
not actually the issue here no Adama
glare the self-proclaimed aim on the
part of the ANS you was through these
killings to strike fear in the heart of
the migrants in Germany and eventually
make them leave this country make them
leave Germany I think at least in that
regard it's I think it's fair to say
that they want that they won't succeed
no no no I
bizarrely enough not seen its you made
us migraines you no doubt in parts or
home or country it was a reaction of the
security sources which make me a little
nervous but you know but no matter what
the neo-nazis are doing they are not
going to drive out of my country because
this is my country this is my home and
this nothing they can do about that but
we are society we have to respond to the
neo-nazi threat and we have had like two
hundred thousand neo-nazi crime since
1990s okay a year of our unification
this is not a threat to the migrant
communities a strike for our society for
democracy that's why we have to fight
again it and maybe this is our call for
action and we should start now and those
actions indeed are not only directed
towards migrants but still some people
are saying there is a tendency to
downplay an underestimate right-wing
extremism in Germany on the part of the
majority society would you agree I think
I mean there's a lot of the the German
society was very happy and I don't
misunderstand this but I mean they were
there was a certain amount of relief
that it was East Germans killing Turks
you don't I mean I say you know these
are two groups that we don't need to
worry of marginalized and we don't need
to to you know feel that any that we've
been involved in any of the problems and
a lot of the network you know that it
did help them was west german karin I
mean and they you know a lot of they
were the west german neo-nazi scene for
years before they went out into their
killings brief so I mean it's just kind
of nonsense and you know we look at this
truck we've been talking about this
trial in the beginning let the minute it
started had already been adjourned
hasn't it we're looking at a very long
and thorny road you know until we can
actually reach a ruling here absolutely
I think just the fact and not being a
legal expert but the fact that the judge
immediately just took this time because
he realized he need my interpretive this
he needed this time in order to figure
out okay how are we going to go but the
trial on the first day
I kept thinking of the American word
filibuster where you're just trying to
hold it up and this guy was reading on
and on and on and the room is packed and
though the air is just heavy and we were
all struggling upstairs to stay awake I
mean I can't imagine what the victims
must have been thinking as well I don't
know if they were actually prepared for
it's it's it's the way the legal system
works obviously and we have to go
through that process and there will be
other points where where witnesses are
question at all but it's definitely it's
not going to be an easy trial on any
fronts for anyone involved mmm
atomically a lot of witnesses will be
hurt in this trial at the end what would
you what would the most desired outcome
be of this trial if it were up to you
justice justice I mean this is what a
trial is about what would justice be in
this case full investigation and if the
indictment is true and i believe it is
mrs. church AP should never be become a
threat again at least not for the next
20 25 years but we'll see this trial is
not a sprint it's a marathon and we have
just started this is not a sprint by the
marathon indeed and we just got Gus get
started indeed I want to thank my guess
I want to thank John Gertz mammoth I'm
Aguilera necessary for shedding some
light on this very complicated and
intricate path towards finding justice
at the end of the day thank you out
there for tuning in and looking forward
to seeing you again next week for a new
edition of quadriga
you